Nigerien Nigerien my dear
compatriots
the power
I also reaffirm our availability for
any dialogue as long as it takes into
account the orientations desired by the
proud and resilient Nigerien people
any portitive approach and ignore the
quest for sovereignty, security and
good governance clearly expressed
by  the population amounts to ignoring the
deep dynamics at work in the
Saharan countries abandoned to their own
fate for more than 10 years by the
very people who instead of helping them to
fight the words which assail them,
today want to attack them in
short  one of the national council for the
protection of the homeland nor the
Nigerien people want a war and
remain open to dialogue but
we understand well
if an aggression were to be undertaken
against us it will not be the
walk in the park for which  it is a
belief
in fact that
he will find
26 million Nigeriens facing them